single-use plastic is pretty much
everywhere and the Premier League on
match days is no exception for now a new
partnership between the league and sky
will see top-flight football working to
remove plastic from its operations and
supply chains there's way too much being
used around the ground there's a benefit
I don't see why anyone would have a
opposed to it
Tottenham Hotspur is one of the first
clubs to declare its commitment to
phasing out single-use plastic I mean
our main aim is that when we start is to
have it everything 50% recycled I think
in the country the moments about 33% of
everything that can be recycled is being
recycled we're looking at getting a 50%
target to start with and hopefully
aiming for 80 percent target within a
few years
all Premier League clubs are being
encouraged to follow their lead
when spars move into their new home next
season there won't be any plastic
cutlery straws are stirrers available
and all of the clubs retail outlets will
no longer offer 5p plastic bags in a
statement the Premier League's executive
chairman Richards Scudamore said we're
able to use the worldwide reach and
appeal of the Premier League to raise
awareness of this environmental issue
and will be working with clubs to
support them in their efforts to reduce
plastic usage here you are at halftime
you've got your point takes you 15
minutes to drink that pint that plastic
cup that plastic glass it's going to
exist on our planet for centuries so now
we know that we can never go backwards
we've got to go forwards we've got to
use brand new materials it's gonna be so
much easier than we think this is an
ambitious project that will need fan
support if it's to succeed but a plastic
free Premier League would be a win for
everyone
and the Brady Sky News in North London